el Jurado en cannes viajó a túnez y a
Turquía con dos películas proyectadas en
la competencia
[Música]
la directora tunicina couter presentó
ante el Jurado de cannes las hijas de
Alfa una película experimental femenina
y difícil sobre una mujer que enfrenta
la radicalización de sus hijas
[Música]
la película abarca un período de diez
años y cuenta la historia de olfa una
mujer de origen humilde quien ve la
huida de dos de sus cuatro hijas quienes
deciden enrolarse en la organización
terrorista estado islámico la cinta
afronta de manera frontal e intimista el
dolor la culpabilidad la negación de la
realidad y el miedo
adicción
el reconocido director Turco Nuri bilje
ceyland quien ya ganó la palma de oro en
2014 regresó a la competencia este año
con hierba seca hierba seca cuenta la
historia de samed un joven profesor en
un pueblo perdido de anatolia quien
espera una mutación a la capital
Estambul una serie de eventos le hacen
perder toda Esperanza hasta que conoce a
nuray una joven profesora como él quien
lo seduce con su inteligencia Y
radicalismo hierba seca es una de las
películas más largas de la competencia
este año más de tres horas de duración
pero donde se capta la belleza del
invierno y las sombras de un personaje
manipulador